Hello everybody.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Welcome back!
Episode 3 of the Wolf Amogas.
Today I'm a little more dark mode, so to match the very
cool, very dark atmosphere we have going on.
I thought maybe it's a little more.
A little more fitting.
But yeah.
Oh my gosh.
We ended off last time.
So crazy.
Crayd was doing his snow white role playing.
And we had that other...
We had Lily, Holly's sister.
We found her body.
And she was actually glamored to look like snow white.
So Snow White is actually okay.
Shock.
But I'm excited to see where this goes because, my goodness,
I did notice something too.
I was looking at the Book of Fables.
And would you look at this?
I missed two.
One from chapter one and one from chapter two.
But we have all these for chapter three.
Or episode three, sorry.
And episode four and episode five.
So...
And we got mostly everything.
Very interesting that I missed two though.
The game has some replayability.
So maybe if you play the game, you can see what those two
slots are.
But for now, let's not waste any more time.
I'm so excited.
Like I said, I really want to see where this goes.
So episode three.
Oh, episode 3, A Crooked Mile.
What are we doing, chasing after the car?
I'm so excited to see Bigby transform.
We got that dog in us.
Let's go.
Our stories used to be so simple.
We had a beginning, a middle, and an end.
Icky, Icky bond trade.
Everything's gotten so confused.
Look, I didn't kill anyone.
This guy's so smug it makes me...
want to want to rip off his nose i didn't do anything you
don't need to look at me i just want you to be careful i
almost lost you once and i'm not yours to lose i'm not going
to be an errand girl for crane anymore yeah it's not holly
it's not holly it's her sister lily she was hooking to pay
down debt eventually the only people she owed were at her
work You know, that shithole club.
Oh, oh, come on, please.
Don't make me have to censor more.
Oh, Marissa.
I've got some questions.
Not to be confused with the Ravencroft variety.
Open arms.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah, we also saw that beauty was working here.
That's what her little secret is.
She's got a part-time job.
It's Crane.
Ew.
So icky.
Icky, icky photo.
Such a great shot.
We're stewing.
We're not going to say anything.
Crane?
God, you think you know a person.
Bigby, you have to tell her.
I know.
What's going on?
What did you find up there?
You know, other than the...
Crane is the killer.
I don't think we think that's the case, but...
Oh, that's right.
Everything's going to be fine.
Okay, it's going to be fine.
Snow is in danger.
Hurted little fucker might be after snow.
Not might.
I need to find her right now.
Okay, it's going to be okay.
Where did you see her last?
Did she say where she was going?
She took Holly to the business office.
Oh, that's right.
To prepare for the funeral.
Lily's funeral?
yeah how do you know i was just at the trip trap and i heard
gren telling some folks about a funeral at the buckingham
bridge trap are you drinking right now they were on their
way out oh oh bigby that that they have their own problems
to settle wait what why are we telling me to wait snow's
snow's been through a lot there are things she doesn't talk
about just please be careful What do you mean?
What are you trying to say?
Yeah, what do you...
You know how you felt when you saw that picture?
Well, it's going to be much worse for her.
Just remember that.
You know, I really...
She doesn't talk to, like, any of the dwarves, right?
Or rather, we haven't seen them, so I'm assuming that maybe
something happened.
That's...
Like, you know, she doesn't talk to them anymore because of
it.
Maybe?
Question?
Also, in the book, they looked so, like, menacing.
What happened to Dopey?
Sleepy.
Sneasy.
And Doc.
Oh, okay.
I was like, is this part of a ritual?
But it must be part of the funeral.
Oh, they're talking about her.
She's like, Don't come here.
If you're here, then you are part of a very special Let's
wave her over.
Let's...
Yes, yes, please.
Uh, yes, please.
I won't, um, offend you by claiming one day that the pain of
losing Lily will ever subside.
I know as well as it will never subside.
Yeah, bottle of liquor.
But the memory of Lily will sustain as well.
And it will, in time, equal in strength to our mourning.
her loss.
I'll miss worrying about you.
I'll miss our fights.
I'll miss you.
Holly.
Your memories of her.
How she could be stubborn and patient, rash, and strong.
Now you will never die from indifference.
She carried a torch for the old ways, for tradition, for
goodbye, sweetheart.
Thanks for everything.
And most of all, it seems how Lily loved, dearly loved her
friends and family you were a big bright shining star in
this shithole of a town I never met Lily I miss you already
everybody all of the cards are like bridges is that like a
troll culture thing okay she's done so come here you're
having your moment of silence you're finished uh you know to
leave we need to leave something's happened we have to get
out of here pick me what the hell are you doing I didn't
interrupt anything is everything okay you waited for stone
to finish wait a second which is it which is it which is it
he has no right to be here not after what he did I don't
want trouble I don't want to what did I do look Holly not
here to start troubling you throw my sister down the
witching well and you have the nerve to show your face here
I didn't do that after you lie and you say you need her for
evidence Holly wait that was Crane just Crane he disposed of
Lily's body before Big B could do anything about it I'm
telling you the truth don't cover for him oh this genuinely
wasn't his yeah Crane's a fucking prick so this doesn't
surprise me yeah hey what do you know we actually agree on
that he's trying to help and I'm sure he has a very good
reason for being here I do this one isn't on him I have a
very good reason why are you here anyway I think I know say
it's because you care about I'm here to talk everything okay
yeah I'm here to I'm it's I'm here to talk to snow yeah I'm
not here to interrupt a funeral this is serious why does
nobody ever believe when we say that things They're serious.
Bigby and I are going to have a little chat far away from
the ceremony, all right?
Yes.
You can continue it.
Holly, I know how this must...
No, you don't know how this must feel.
You have no idea.
Don't fuck anything up.
Don't bother anybody.
And when the first sign of trouble comes, and it will come
because you're a goddamn walking trap for it, I want you the
fuck out of here.
You hear me?
I just want Lily's killer.
Just want to get Lily's killer, Holly.
Let's just continue, okay?
This is such total fucking bullshit.
Oh.
Let's go, Holly.
Oh, I wonder who she is.
It's your turn to talk.
Maybe like Rapunzel or something.
I feel like because the hair is so short, it feels like
she's like anti-Rapunzel, you know?
She's like, I gotta have my hair really short.
This better be wildly important.
It's been hard enough making a connection with these people.
When you pull this kind of stuff, it just resets the clock.
Crane's obsessed with you.
No, Crane is completely obsessed with you.
Oh, my God.
If this is about how Crane treats me at work...
Just listen to me for a second, all right?
I followed a lead to this shithole motel, the open arms.
Yeah.
Crane had a room there, and he's been taking prostitutes, or
at the very least, Lily, and making her look like you while
he was...
He plays your story over and over again.
This is...
I don't even know what to say right now.
This poor girl.
I really don't.
First someone...
First she discovers her...
Discover someone...
I'm just trying everything I can right now to not picture
it.
We should leave.
Yeah, we should go.
You're sure this is what happened?
This is what he's been doing?
Because please, Bigby, don't confuse things.
Crane took photos.
Let's not show her.
Lots of photos.
Uh...
Photos that show...
show him he's been recording his visits with lily god look
let's go back to the business office i doubt crane's there
at this hour but we need to talk and this isn't the place
yeah we i agree no marissa what is it i'm sorry but holly's
asking for you are they starting the burn yes everyone who
spoke should really be present for this part she's kind of
distraught I mean...
Yeah, yeah.
I don't mean to be...
No, I understand.
We'll just...
It's just that something's come up.
We'll just, you know, we'll just...
Yeah, let her do her thing.
I will wait.
It's just, what, two minutes?
How'd it go at the motel?
Did you find anything?
Did we?
Uh...
Lily was killed there.
Yeah, Lily was killed there.
It was an awful mess.
oh i'm sorry maybe we didn't need to tell that yeah um
coming yeah um yeah
not great constable wait wait wait easy oh you you how did
you put the first thing in a visit you say how do you do how
do you do yeah They're about to regret this.
But it won't do any good.
Just make it more fun for me.
That's not at all what I picked, but whatever.
You ain't too fast enough pup to prevent me from emptying
both barrels into Snow White's face over there.
We'll snip to the chase for all sakes.
A little bird told us that you're fitting to go after Crane.
Wait, how does everybody know this now?
And you see, we have an interest in that particular boy.
So you leave Crane alone, and we'll leave you alone.
you work for crane are you working for crane did he send you
no see now you're already asking too many questions just pay
attention so what's it gonna be we have a deal you leave
crane alone this funerals getting crashed by everybody just
don't speak your mind fastly now just don't hurt anyone hurt
anyone D that don't sound like a yes to me always wanting to
do things the fun way don't do it gentlemen invertebrates
please rest easy this is not the hell is going on what's
happening very sorry to impose but we only had a deal to
work out with Bigby and we're unhappy to report that things
did not go as smoothly as planned wait Bigby what is he
talking I don't know never you mind that it ain't any of
your deal no deal I'm not Get the fuck out of here and leave
these people alone.
Yeah.
Nah.
What did I tell you?
What did I say?
Holly?
Actually, she's totally valid.
You think you could just fucking interrupt Lily's funeral?
Calm down, darling.
It was just a simple business transaction.
They look terrified.
You fucking freaks are not getting away with this.
Holly, don't move.
Uh, yeah, it's not worth it, Holly.
They'll leave on the phone.
on yeah let's spare all the fuss it's just a dead hole i'm
gonna kill you
i mean she's a fable i got it done uh kick him kick him in
the tummy yeah there he goes uh i'm gonna grab that
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
That was me.
What, uh...
What a show at the funeral.
She's not dead, is she?
No.
She's...
She could tank it.
Right?
I maybe could have handled that better.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's fine, probably, maybe.
Holy.
Holy cow, everything is all...
Everybody's always so aggressive.
Maybe we could all talk this over some pie.
The name of that club made me want some pie.
So, so.
Episode 3, A Crooked Mile.
Who is that guy?
I did as well as I could to take out the buckshot But
there's Oh, it's probably the Dr. Swine's man They'll
eventually warm their way out on their own But until they
do, you're gonna be sore Big B, Dr. Swinehart was appointed
Fable Town physician for a reason It's okay There's only one
thing you have to take away from all this Take it easy Okay
Don't go looking for any more fights Keep strain off your
heart How is everyone else?
Yeah, actually I'm curious everyone else they all make it
they're fine oh okay i had everyone that got wounded sent
home holly refused to let me see where she lived so i left
her and grendel back at her bar with a dose of juniper and
springwater the titans baby they'll be fine that's what i
was saying they're just remember what i said the stitches
won't hold up if you continue to act like you rationally
like i normally do and uh eat more chicken your blood
pressure the proverbial roof too big it easy is not really
my thing doc well whatever your thing is try and make it
work better for you next time dang business office i know
i'll have to call you back what's that the town is starting
to find out about what well i'll leave you two to it then
miss white bigby about crane good let them know let the
whole world know oh the mirror the magical mirror to recap
crane watch me through the magic mirror uncover his room at
the open arms and then he smashed it so we couldn't use it
ourselves to go after and we know this because buffkin was
drinking in the rafters and once he puts all the pieces back
together it'll be easy to catch crane yeah that's the plan
currently but i i don't know we don't have time to wait for
them but yeah great it's getting away if we don't get on a
train right now yeah i don't want to just go running off
into the night without some direction what the hell is going
on all right buffkin we need you to hurry up then i don't
know what the tweedles get out of this i don't know if crane
sent them i don't know if i mean this is gonna sound crazy
but do you really think crane did it everything points to
him i get it but do you really that's what i was saying
though that's what i was thinking just it's incomprehensible
i'm not sure he killed them you are to be honest i don't
think he killed them i think he's a little freakazoid with
snow white story but i don't think he killed them he's he
was a conniver a coward a liar and i always hate him for
that and i hate him for how he held me in his thoughts oh
that's a way to put it murdering prostitutes Everything okay
over there?
Yes, Miss White.
I just cut myself on a piece of the glass.
Nothing to worry about.
Thanks for tonight, by the way.
That could have gone really terribly.
I mean, even worse than it did.
It did go pretty bad.
I'm glad you were there.
I feel bad for Holly.
I just feel bad for Holly, really.
Yeah.
Time heals everything eventually.
At least I hope so, for her sake.
can i um ask you a question it's kind of personal uh oh and
i don't want to offend you oh but after tonight it's on my
mind what's on your mind snow white when stuff hits the fan
like like it did tonight yeah it feels like before we came
to the city it feels kind of like home and i've heard it
said that maybe in some tiny little bottled up way deep
inside you kind of enjoy it when things go wrong oh because
it gives you an excuse you enjoy all the killing you know
stop pretending pretending oh oops i wasn't fast enough i
guess it doesn't matter is my silence my silence might be an
answer guys we have a problem Did he take a piece?
I can't finish the mirror.
It's missing a piece.
Oh my god.
That guy sucks.
What do you mean missing a piece?
Yes, it's a...
Crane must have taken it.
I must have taken a shard with him.
Yeah.
I can't believe this.
Look the floating ship in the background.
I saw Crane pick something up after he smashed it.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize what it was until now.
Well, the mirror can't work unless it's whole.
Oh, no.
Well, that's not entirely true.
Oh?
Or what, Bufkin?
What?
We sit around and wait until...
until it mends itself we have no idea how long that will
take yeah buffkin we're just gonna have to do this the hard
way i'm just saying waiting is an option oh no what's the
hard way depend on the mirror what exactly is the hard way
we'll look through his things his desk everything he had to
have left something that tells us where he's going he's a
neat freak but he was never that smart it's hard enough to
take a piece of the mirror oh damn okay we can still solve
this ourselves
Oh, this is what you didn't want to do before.
You were like, we can't go blindly, blah, blah, blah.
We have to depend on the mirror.
And now the mirror's not going to be fixed, and you...
Bufkin, how long will it take?
The mirror can just fix itself?
I mean, I guess it is magical, but...
Hi, Mr. Bigby.
I can still help you catch Crane, you know.
Yeah?
Oh, yeah?
Yes.
I saw him jump on the telephone before he left.
Oh, he called up somebody.
He said he needed to see his witch.
His witch?
for that whoever that is his witch yes it sounded like the
one he got his snow glimmers from oh yeah that girl's my
witch um why didn't you stop why didn't you try and stop
them what do you want me to do yank on his hair I'm only
three feet tall there are limits here you are okay okay you
were you were one of the okay I'm sorry but weren't the
monkeys and Oz like soldiers like I do not do not doubt the
strength of a primate they like there are stories of people
getting mauled by by by primates and stuff i watched uh what
was that movie i watched uh what was that movie the jordan
peel one i don't remember get not get out uh up one with the
alien Did you see anything else?
You didn't see anything else, did you?
No, not, uh, not especially.
You're not lying to me.
Do we want to say that it's not his fault?
We were pretty mean to Bufkin before.
We can keep being mean to Bufkin.
I'll just see if I can do anything about this.
You do that.
What are we looking for?
I'm choosing this.
okay oh 207 oh my gosh he had the key here the entire time
i'm gonna scream
miss crane oh sorry mr mr crane mr crane you said you'd pay
to have the plaster redone in my building after the last
incident in 204 it's falling off the effing walls please fix
it i can't rent out that room as it is and i've already been
waiting for days Not to mention, you already promised you'd
send someone to fix the big crack in the glass on the front
door.
Well, guess what?
It's worse now!
Get your shit together!
Mr. Toad.
Okay, Mr. Toad is not helpful.
I'll see this one.
Dear Ichabod Cricht, I am writing to ask again that you
please send someone to fix the air conditioning in our unit.
It's burning up in the apartment, and Pinocchio says his
skin is splintering.
I don't know what that means.
But does wood splinter if it gets too hot?
But I assume it's something gross, and I'd really like it if
you fixed the air like we asked you three months ago.
At the very least, provide us a fan in the meantime.
Sincerely, boy blue.
I'm not familiar with that.
Tale either, I think.
Nicobod, great.
Are there any updates on the extra funding I requested?
last letter, the conditions here could do with some
improvement.
I'm seeing some unrest from the residents, and I have to
admit I can see why.
The farm should not be a punishment.
I'm sure you're busy, but I think this should be made a
priority.
Best Wayland Smith.
Did Crane ever do any work?
I'm wondering that, too!
was around.
The key...
What is it?
It's the key to his room at the open arms.
You still haven't told me what was in there.
I want to know.
You don't want to know.
I don't think you...
Don't cuddle me, okay?
I've seen more than you know.
There's only so much you can repress, you know.
We'll get him, yeah.
Don't worry, Snow.
We'll get him.
Yeah, we'll get his butt.
Come on, let's keep looking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's in the drawer?
Does he yank it?
Yeah.
What is that?
The little smirk at each other.
The Office of Business Affairs?
Official something, something, something.
There's a page here that was torn out.
Oh, yeah?
Bafkin, do you know what was here?
The key.
It's a ring, at least.
Every magical item not retained in the armory is assigned to
someone in Fable Town.
It must be this witch he is going to see.
Wait, what witch?
Bufkin overheard Crane set up a meeting with a witch.
Well, yes, it sounded like the one he got his, uh, you,
glimmers from.
It must be about this ring.
Why not mention this before?
No one asked me.
Is this the thing that maybe Faith stole?
Oh, but no, the ring that she...
had was for the donkey what's going on is the mirror fixed
yet bluebeard this isn't the time it was like her family
insignia or something you called me just to see if you knew
where crane could be and that was it okay and i'm sorry i
said anything more than that well you did and i know who is
this guy why is he involved so can we find the dull pervert
or not no it can't be fixed it's missing a piece yeah none
of bluebeard's business pick me none of my business Crane's
the murderer.
He escaped.
It seems he's spoiled your every attempt at locating him.
And now it's none of my business?
We don't know if he's the murderer.
Oh, please.
Of course he is.
Look, this just isn't the time.
He took a piece of the mirror so we can't use it.
Yeah.
The only thing we know is that Crane's going to see a witch
at 2 o'clock.
Buffkin, your big old mouth!
AM or PM?
AM.
Listen, dear.
You're not a part of this.
I don't think you're in any position to turn away here.
What do you know about Crane anymore?
Yeah.
That he has the stones to kill prostitutes like any common
sex-frightened serial killer and not face a real challenge.
Look, we know that Crane is going to see a witch and it's to
acquire a magic ring.
What's the ring?
We don't know what it does or who it's designed to do.
Oh, we're just telling him everything now, okay.
Crane tore its page out of the book.
This farce was your ridiculous idea for a man.
I need who put you in charge in the first place.
logical you're a secretary he's a sheriff and none of you
are chosen to run this office who elected you to make these
decisions nobody but who elected her to spin my money well
i've been doing that i'm heading this investigation yeah i'm
heading up the investigation okay blue beard that makes this
a moot point yeah exactly he needs to run the business
office while he does so yeah yeah well then excuse me for
having the commonwealth in mind what do we do what do you
Who are you?
Just look on the bright side.
We know Crane is going to see the witch that's been
supplying him black market glamours.
Thanks to me.
And that he'll be there at two.
So that gives us a few short hours to find out who it is and
where they live and get them all at once.
And a few shorter hours, the more you babble about it.
We haven't been the ones babbling.
Tell me what it was.
Yeah, yeah.
Just point in the direction you want me to check first.
used the glamours she'd have known who the witch was and i
don't think holly's burned her things yet it would probably
have the address or a phone number or something and bigby is
free to go there if he likes but i think the question you
should be asking is just what do the two tweedles know about
yeah that's true it doesn't matter what they know after
tonight they'd never go to their office they're not smart
enough to try and go anywhere else the trip trap is the
better option to track the witch down i don't know has to be
our focus uh even if they're not there the tweedle's office
they might though right crane or the witch i don't really
care what you two do i'm going to his apartment what you
can't just go up there and why the hell not we already
looked for the key remember i don't know where it is then
i'll pick the blasted lock i've wasted enough time waiting
for the mirror to find him i won't waste anymore you just
can't go up there alone all right i have no interest in
nicking his drapes my dear if that's what concerns you what
concerns me is you traipsing through possible evidence oh
now stay out of this just stay out of it all right you'll
just mess things up further they can't get any more messed
up oh that's fine we have to find the witch blue beard since
that's where he's going yeah or the sniveling weasel
chickened out never went anywhere and is upstairs right now
in his pitiful penthouse crafting a fort out of couch
cushions.
Okay, then go up there.
I don't know.
This is how a smart person would do it.
So this is how we're going to do it.
Wherever you go, I'll go to the other.
I don't like you going anywhere unsupervised.
He's up to something.
I don't know what it is, but we don't have the time to
really worry about anything.
I think maybe because we didn't figure out or we didn't hear
anything about this guy in episode one, I'm like so confused
who he is.
You know what I mean?
Like, what is your relation to any of this?
What do you do?
Find the witch.
That's...
What I gotta do?
Oh my gosh, okay.
So you leave Crane alone?
And we'll leave you alone.
I'd love to join you, but there's some business I need to
attend to.
No, I'm better up dealing with things alone.
I don't need sympathy and I don't need charity.
Ah!
Sorry, I went to the bathroom.
Okay, I am thinking the best place to look if we're trying
to find where Crane went.
I don't think Holly's bar is going to have anything, right?
Like, I don't quite understand.
Sorry, I was distracted while they were all yelling at each
other.
But I feel like maybe.
Holly's, if we're looking for, like, anything involving
Crane, like, D's office, D's?
D's office might be the best bet if they're, like, working
for him?
I mean, Crane's apartment also might be good, because, I
mean, obviously, that's where he would keep, that's where he
lived, like, it might, he might have, like, a note of about
the witch, If Tweedledee and Tweedledum are working for
Crane, then maybe they have something, or maybe they just
know about the witch in general, and that might be a good
lead.
I think an office sounds more...
Like, full of stuff.
I don't know, an apartment does too.
But you know what I mean?
Like, an office sounds more full of, like, paperwork and
things than somebody's apartment.
That's how my mind is imagining it.
So I'm going to go to the office.
So you leave Crane alone, and we leave you alone.
You and all your acquaintances.
I'm going to get...
He and Dumb must know where he is.
I should go to their office first.
Perfect.
And I'll go to Crane's apartment.
Yeah, he left.
I'll look up their address.
I hope you know what you're doing.
I mean...
I don't know.
Tweedle...
Tweedle Brothers office.
office is this shaggy excuse me oh hi sheriff bigby great
great to see you i don't know if you remember me i've uh
seen you around but you may have forgotten i know who you
are fly catcher fly catcher at the woodlands for how many
years now i think i've lost count fly catcher uh let me go
recently oh yeah yeah i mean it's no big deal oh so what
brings you here i mean can i help you with anything are you
here to see one of the brothers uh have you seen crane
actually you've seen crane around not around here i saw him
leave the woodlands earlier but i'm not supposed to oh okay
i don't really think he likes me this guy is sweeping and
we're dumping our ashes on the floor i think the twins are
out okay probably working on a case sometimes i don't see
them for days they gave me the job after crane told me to
get lost Take the night off.
Why don't you take the night off?
That's nice of you.
But I can't.
I still have to clean their office.
I can let you in if you want.
Oh, yeah.
That, uh, nice guy.
No problem.
Oh, thank you.
Look at their little collection of hats.
I'm gonna have to take a look around.
Uh, well, I guess that would be okay.
I wasn't really asking for permission.
Right.
You're the sheriff.
I just don't want to get in trouble or anything.
Oh, sure, sure.
You're fine.
I won't I won't get you in trouble yeah don't worry I won't
get you in trouble right right making this guy have to come
on big B please they have a punching bag with a big bad wolf
on it what didn't big bad wolf ever do to tweedle D and
tweedle Dumb cigar box is it empty oh you know about this no
no what do they got in their inbox dear brother D I think we
should get ourselves a dog sincerely brother duck he
actually mailed this they do have their quirks this is
pointless brothers brothers I always wanted a brothers
brothers it's not pointless yet there's an inbox what did
else what else did they say into each other.
Dear brother dumb, I hate dogs and you know it.
Sincerely, brother D.
This is so stupid.
I know these guys can come off abrasive at times, but they
aren't so bad once you get to know them.
What is their job anyway?
They're kind of loud at times, but you get used to it.
How do you mean they help people?
They're detectives.
Anyone can come in here with a problem and they'll be the
best to fix it.
The way D explains it, it's like if someone lost their cat,
well they could hire them to, you know, track it down.
Oh my God, they actually have the tweedle D and tweedle dumb
hat right there on the top.
They can be like couriers, you know?
Or who?
All kinds.
Come to think of it, I don't really know where they keep
them.
Keep the who, the them what?
Anyways, I'm just saying, you just don't know them like I
do.
Sure, flycatcher.
Okay.
He's getting like defensive on their behalf.
Lollipops, don't touch.
okay okay okay interesting though if we ever see like a
lollipop stick we'll know somebody was there maybe we do
have this filing cabinet but let's let's look in here first
let's see if they got a file on a crane
beauty Brannigan Cinderella crane donkey skin wait that's
important too though
stole a photo from crane hired them to look for a photo so
that's why they were at her apartment and the woodsman's
place see I knew you wouldn't find anything anything of
interest anyways they're detectives like I said I'm finding
enough I'm just saying look hey just trust me on this
tweedle D and dumb are not nice they're not helping anyone
well I They helped me.
Okay, great.
They helped you.
That's one person.
Now, please, just let me concentrate here.
She stole a photo.
Interesting.
What do they have on beauty?
I'm being nosy now.
Oh, this is her!
This is worse than I thought.
Georgie has an interest.
Shit.
Ew, Georgie has a interest.
an interest oh wait it's i'm not clicking anything it's
going through it too fast for me to like read them what the
heck is branigan detective branigan oh keep an eye on her
entire police precinct falls asleep for hours that's right
he did that the memory erase spell cinderella
where's cindy been vacation apparently crisp and says
somewhere in europe she didn't look like the girl with the
short hair I don't think Ichabod crane Ichabod crane he owes
the crooked man money shit how is he planning to pay this
all back who the heck is the crooked man request for
property acquisition further details filed under
compromising photo why did he want it back so badly yeah
what kind of photo I mean what I need what if you're wrong
about them I not they're misunderstood sure but that doesn't
mean everything people say about them is true this guy's
their biggest fan you know like when I think about it you
guys aren't that different you help people and they help
people not that it's any of my business is that what you
think oh shit there's something here I know there is there
has to be why would there be anything because they're lying
to you okay flycatcher that's why they They aren't
detectives.
They're hired hitmen.
They're hired guns.
Hitmen.
Are they?
I think...
Bigby, what happened to your...
Oh, no.
I don't know what this is.
This is them showing up to Lily's funeral with fucking
shotguns.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
Look, I know you like them.
Yeah.
I catch her up.
I know you like them, but they're a part of whatever is
happening here.
They're bad guys.
Ew, our stitches.
Oh, geez.
we got all worked up we got all worked up is there anything
you know anything fly catcher I didn't mean to oh there's a
door behind this file cabinet I don't know what they keep
back here but it might be what you're looking for oh we
convinced him that key you found should work oh I thought
the key was gonna be to the file cabinet.
Fly catcher, why would any innocent person have a, like, you
know, like a room like this?
You don't know what's in there.
Uh-huh.
Wait, it looks like they're doing the magic down here,
right?
Wow.
Like how we just followed us.
We got coffee.
Yeah, see?
They're doing, they're making stuff.
They're the witch!
Nah, I don't know about that.
The package?
What's this package?
It says coffee.
Oh, butcher.
What is this stuff?
What are you looking for exactly?
Maybe I can help.
Anything about crane.
Oh.
Or the witch he was using.
Something.
Oh.
ASAP.
Crooked man.
I'm sorry.
I know I'm late.
I'll get it to you soon.
Ichabod Crane.
Who is he sending money to?
Crooked Man.
Care of the Lucky Pond.
Do you know what that is?
I'm taking the money.
If it's going to make Ichabod be bad to the Crooked Man.
I don't think so.
It's interesting.
There's more going on here.
I'm pocketing that.
I still need to find that witch, though.
All right, let me look around.
Quit yapping.
What's this thing?
Little package.
ASAP.
Hey, Big B.
Yeah?
Do you think, after all this, do you think I could come back
to the woodlands?
Oh.
Since Crane let me go, I mean, I can still work here, but I
don't think I want to now.
Oh.
I don't want to work with bad people.
You should talk to snow.
I don't hire people for you.
Yeah, really?
That would be thank you.
I don't I don't hire people I'm just a I'm just a that's her
hair.
It's snow's hair.
Yeah Snow white Why we found her hair like this inside
Lily's glamour Auntie green leaf.
Oh, we got a lead the witch crane was using I guess we got a
lead getting the hair for crane and sending it to her.
Ew, how are they getting her hair?
There's no address on it.
So what now?
Snow would probably want to know about this.
Maybe Buffkin found something.
Yeah.
Wonder if Buffkin and Snow had any luck.
Maybe they found an address.
Yeah.
Or can check for a record on Anti-Greenleaf.
I think I saw a phone near the back.
I like how we're just explaining everything to this guy.
Thanks.
Oh, we said thank you.
You're welcome, Sheriff.
Aww.
Don't betray me, please.
Hey, Snow.
Oh, it's you.
Sorry.
I've been answering angry phone calls for hours.
People want to know what Crane is.
How'd it go with the Tweddle brothers?
No address yet, but I got a name for Crane's witch.
Anti-Greenleaf.
No.
I'll get Bufkin started looking for a record, but it might
take some time.
Huh.
Somebody's got to know where to find her.
And Snow, I found a note with some money attached.
Crane has been embezzling from Fabled Town.
That's crazy.
he's cleaning in here don't do that it's probably connected
I think it's connected maybe the girls found out about it I
don't know maybe you might want to try Holly's place see if
she hasn't burned Lily's things yet or Crane's you might
find something there although Bluebeard's been there I'll
leave it up to you but you don't have much time Crane is
meeting her at two I'll go to...
I'll go to...
Well, actually Lily might have gone rather than like Crane,
you know, to get the...
to get like the the thing, you know, it had like use this,
like we don't know if she got it from Crane herself or if
she got it from the witch, you know.
I'll go to the trip.
I'll go to the trip trap, see about Lily's things.
I think that's our Yeah, I'll try it.
Just... just be gentle with Holly when you get there, okay?
Of course, of course.
I'm a gentle guy.
I'm a gentle giant.
Let me know what he comes up with.
I'll be in touch.
Why are we so focused on him?
Stop cleaning!
They need to look like no one's been down here.
I have to go.
Someone just came in.
Good luck.
Boy, oh, oh, okay.
We looked at everything, I guess then.
Oh, close.
Do to bereave it.
45 minutes left?
I could kick down the door.
What's left to explain?
I can talk to the door.
I'm just going to open.
I'm just going out of here.
Excuse me, knock, knock.
Oh, that's not at all what we were trying to do.
Read the sign.
I'm knocking I'm knocking oh I'm doing it angrily it's me
big be it's me big be let me in hey look what he it's the
sheriff they like me now come on in buddy oh he likes me now
yeah I'm your buddy I'm your pal.
Friend.
What?
I need to see Lily's things.
A weary traveler in search of some hospitality, right?
Yeah.
I'll only be here two minutes.
I just need to check through Lily's things.
Hmm.
Whatever.
Why is it?
Okay.
It's being a little...
I'm suspicious.
Why are you being so nonchalant about this, huh?
Hello?
I want a drink.
Anybody else want a drink?
Friend.
Swinehart said you.
you shouldn't make you think I give a fuck what that fucking
guy says or what you say oh woodsman he looks like such a
you shouldn't drink right now I can't hear you when you
mumble yeah swineheart told me that Holly was here I need to
talk to her Holly's asleep in back but you won't be able to
wake her really I mean She's recovering from a shot, no.
I gave him both barmesidal ambrosia for the pain.
Yeah.
But the deal is, if you resist going to sleep like I am
right now, it gives you a very, very, very nice high.
Oh, I thought he was drunk.
And he said that he shouldn't mix it with alcohol.
The rut roll.
Yes, he did.
He certainly did.
But let me tell you something.
Have you seen Lily's thing?
Have you seen her sister's thing?
I'm in a bit of a hurry.
Come on.
I saw her come in with something, but I didn't see where she
put it.
Oh, he's being helpful.
Look at him.
Oh, uh-oh.
That funeral back there?
That was a shitty fucking send-off for a pretty okay lady.
Oh.
Wait, why weren't- Yeah, why weren't you there?
Talking to Bigby now, okay?
Yeah, where were you, huh?
I said you being there helped things much.
Don't start nothing.
Who's starting anything?
I'm not.
I'm, you know what?
Let's just, we're just not gonna answer.
It's alright.
I'm too out of it to get into.
I don't, I'm here on a mission.
Let me see the things.
I want to clear the air.
We're all in this dung heap of a fucking shit town together.
We're all gonna have a toast.
All of us.
Ellis, I'm here for one thing.
Yeah, let me in.
Look through Lily's belongings and get out of here.
Yeah, yeah, I know, I know.
And I want to help you, okay?
And I will.
But first, indulge me.
It'll take two seconds.
I know what's been like so defeated.
Is he okay?
After we'll all hunt and peck for Lily's shit or whatever.
Grand Bigby didn't come here to get loaded with you.
I don't want to get loaded with him.
It's just a quick slug.
I'm not going to hurt anybody.
Fine, I'll drink it real fast.
I'll just...
It's just like...
It's apple juice.
To the dead.
the dead it's not poisoned is it is it is this gonna knock
me out did he put his meds in it or something all right now
help me gran the doc said you needed to rest how many times
you fucking gonna warn me about it huh you're not my mother
so just get off my back i said i was sorry all right i can't
do anything about it he flipped the switch so great oh oh oh
come on man uh stop it come on guys come on what more do you
want i can't babysit you guys say here i absolutely cannot
babysit you dumbasses right now and whatever this is so we
can just move past it yeah oh i forgot you haven't heard the
news what news walking lard cake was paying holly's sister
to let him her behind all of our backs and holly had to find
out going through all of her sister's What fun that must
have been.
Trick after trick of this fat ass and Lily.
I didn't plan for that, alright?
And our thing, whatever it was, it wasn't a big deal.
It wasn't.
I never fucked her when she was snowing.
I didn't know nothing about that.
No, but you knew Hollywood flip out.
And you knew for a damn good fucking reason.
Oh my god.
This is so messy.
You know what?
Fuck this.
I don't need this shit.
So messy.
Now you're teary-eyed.
You are always such a low life.
I don't know why I never realized it till now.
What do you think about this fucking loser, Sheriff?
He can think whatever he wants.
I don't give a shit.
Wait, what do you have?
No, that's okay.
Actually...
Because I'll tell you what he thinks.
Wait, wait.
I've got some questions for you.
What possible questions...
Actually, I don't know.
I'm just curious.
I'm just curious what questions we have.
Everything's a problem when I want to talk.
But when the woods...
Did Lily ever mention a witch?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait.
Did she ever mention a witch?
What do you want?
Oh, he's being cooperative.
See, he's like being cooperative.
And you saw Billy.
Did she ever mention anything about a witch?
An auntie?
We didn't talk about work.
All right.
Oh, that's it?
Yeah, why did you run?
Hmm.
Grin.
I don't know where Lily's shit is.
Oh, come on.
Check Holly's room.
I don't know you put on all you did all of this if I were
you I'm not gonna wake around sleepwalkers and trolls I
think that's the rule you said you would help you said you
would help me look actually big B if you excuse me it seems
that I'm gonna pass out what a day all right sheriff what a
fucking day this guy Gren won't remember this the one time.
Hopefully she's not sleeping on top of it because uh, oof.
Uh, we got this is her room?
We got a crate of alcohol.
I don't think that'll...
Oh.
No, she's probably like in the deepest sleep ever of her
life, right?
Um.
Let's examine the cot.
Oh, I think there's her stuff right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just move it, just move it.
She's so asleep her eyes are like a little bit open.
Okay, grab that.
Easy peasy.
I'm the greatest detective ever.
All right, what do we got here?
Oh, wait, that might be an auntie right there.
That person in the photo?
Oh, hello.
Is that you, Woody?
Nope.
Woody, is that you?
Can I ignore her?
Oh, I ignore her.
Boars closed.
And Lily ain't around anyway, so you can run off back to the
woods, I guess.
Oh.
Let's see.
We got a bottle of wine.
Fancy.
oh don't wait did you care about her at all she was a nice
girl ran around too much but a nice i'm not the woodsman
holly it's the sheriff it's big b she might be mad big b
bars closed okay and excuse me but i'm not in the mood for
entertaining okay but what the leave you do what you want
you always do what you want stop interrupting right yeah i'm
the guy that does what he wants i'm the wait that was a the
thing underneath and also what's his name is in the
background oh my gosh this photo is there was the why do you
even come here there's nothing here to investigate i can't
say i was Sorry.
Oh.
I came to say I was sorry, Holly, for the funeral and
everything that's happened.
No, you didn't.
She caught me.
I was trying to be nice.
The brooch.
She caught me in my big, big lie.
I just want her to go to back to sleep.
Okay.
The glamour tube.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I guess we don't really need it anymore but and then the
book wait this might have an address in it or something
right wait be honest sheriff why are you going after him the
guy that killed Lily you could have quit a long time ago but
you're still going why why are you awake this job for a
reason or was this the only thing the business office would
let you do i have a history with the killer oh whoops i
meant to say i'm doing this oh she's asleep i thought so
what do you mean holly will remember that what is she gonna
remember unless she thinks it's because i'm doing it because
it's the only thing the office your glamour on this day and
one of these has to be the witch yeah get glamorous today oh
we found it we got the address yippee hello this is snow
white calling i'm looking for bigby oh hi is anyone there
bigby if you're there pick up okay pick up hello snow oh
thank god tell me you found
Lily's things.
It's on White Plains.
Don't say it out loud.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, somebody might be listening.
Somebody might be holding our hostage.
Uh, let's go.
Yeah, let's go.
I don't want to miss him.
I'll meet you there.
Didn't we only have, like, what, 15 minutes or something
until 2 a.m.?
Completed chapter 4 of episode 3.
Big B!
I just got here.
Don't yell at me.
Me too.
Scaring me.
It's number 23.
I haven't seen it yet.
We're late.
Oh, bro, we are late.
23.
This is it.
All right.
How do you want to do this?
Um, I'm kicking down the door.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
What are you doing?
What does it look like?
Don't just kick it in.
We don't know what's on the other side.
Let's just save the last resort for last.
I'm kicking down the door.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Don't hurt me.
We are so sorry.
We didn't realize.
you were right there are you all right i was gonna open the
door who are you who lives here i'm i'm sorry it's all right
it's it's okay calm down we're not here to hurt you are you
sure i just scared the hell out of her my bad excited
sometimes but that's all over with now i assure you my bad i
didn't think there would be a kid on the other side Rachel
Rachel who are you just so I'm the big bad wolf I'm the
sheriff and this is my partner boss please teach you how do
you do how do you do is there um is there anything you need
we're looking for a man we're looking for a man a skinny
pale nervous fella have you seen him my art teacher says men
are a waste of time do you go to school sometimes sometimes
is there something you want can we look around yeah yeah
yeah if i take just a quick peek around we'll be very quick
and he won't touch anything nope maybe i don't know maybe
one thing whoa now yeah this looks like a witch's apartment
i've been here all night nobody's been here okay sheriff i'm
gonna trust you not break anything don't get me in trouble
what are we looking for specifically what if she's auntie
green if you could still be here yeah we we we busted in the
door so quickly that you know let's see that your mom uh-huh
uh-huh okay record player stove deer skull your mama hunter
oh no she never that was found in the woods around dick's
mountain i think uh-huh uh-huh we got wow there this is such
a cute cozy place no it's pretty rare to see a burner like
this yeah dowdy that's how we like it dowdy what does that
mean we got a record player let me guess big band or
classical honky-tonk I got that honky-tonk in me.
Partition.
Don't mind me.
I'm looking behind it.
She looks awfully nervous.
I mean, sure, someone just kicked down her door.
There's no one here but me.
Are you lying to us, little Rachel?
Because I can sniff out lies.
And also, I can do a lot of...
No, it's been over all night, so...
He's just going to check.
I can do a lot of observing, too.
What is this?
Mommy uses that to carve her trinkets.
It's from the old world.
Oh!
Trinkets?
Um, like glamours?
Nothing that looks like Crane was here either.
See?
Unless.
There's a closet.
Where do you buy your clothes?
At a store.
Oh.
my mommy makes all of mine oh very cool how much longer do
you think it'll be okay rachel i can have my mom call you
later or something why are you here by yourself anyway there
yesterday where is she oh it was a pretty one like where is
your your mom maybe they were meeting at a different
location then the butcher the butcher what's that a package
having to do with someone the butcher wait that's the same
symbol though that was at tweedle d tweedle done yeah
exactly oh shouldn't say that nothing i keep getting whiffs
of that aftershave of his i do too can i go to bed now
please huh is that a glamour tube mommy really doesn't let
anyone play with that just me i've tried i'm just gonna
touch it a little bit oh no no no no no please please please
just put that back exactly where you found it no one is
allowed to play with that all right honey bigby's not going
to break it you don't understand she will freak out if she
discovers i've let people in here and let them touch her
stuff okay she checks all the time to see if things move i
don't want to get in trouble something isn't right are you
kidding it's a glamour tube something's going on here no put
it down please don't this isn't what you think you gotta
believe me the guy isn't here i promise it's gonna be okay
rachel i'm begging you i don't want to get in trouble or the
i had a feeling it hurts when you do it that fast I had a
feeling.
So no more BS.
Yeah.
More lying or more going around the Rosie.
No more bullshit non-sequiturs.
You're done.
It's over.
You're gonna tell me what I want to know right now.
All right.
Start explaining.
And from the beginning.
Tell me where Craves.
None of this pathetic witchcraft crap is gonna prevent me
from prying what I need from your skull.
She's so sad.
She does not even talk.
She hasn't said it.
Single thing.
I have no heavenly idea where he went to.
Oh no, he did leave.
Unless you want a recipe for owl stew.
Why are you protecting him?
The name of everything holy, are you protecting this weasely
scumbag?
Weasel, weasel!
What on earth could he have done to deserve this kind of
loyalty?
Crane could be hollow bones tomorrow, and you wouldn't see
me cry a drop.
But that doesn't mean I can tell you anything.
Oh my god.
don't you who are you protecting yeah for enemies if you're
not protecting crane the butcher the butcher sounds like
someone that could murder something both of your skulls I
can't tell you just you being here is bad enough there's
powers at work here beyond your pathetic authority whatever
it is green leaf whatever it is that's keeping you from
saying something you should I'm the one who knocks.
She's a lot more afraid of me than whatever horse shit you
think will come out to fight you.
And kicks down your door.
You have no idea what's going on, do you?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Okay, you know what I think?
I think we've been more than patient with you.
This witch has been selling illegal glamours that continue
to undermine everything we've built.
She's harboring a fugitive that took advantage of it, and
now she's resisting every attempt to make things right.
I mean, didn't we say that the glamours aren't technically
illegal, but...
sure she never hurts us again are we taking out the tree
we're destroying the tree oh shoot we're taking out oh how
dare you come in here and threaten to take from me the one
thing that that tree is ancient it's part of the family and
it's the only thing paying for this whole apartment and the
famous i think your apartment's quite nice from you come to
me for help without them where do you think they could go
give me that you're making money off of other people's
misery That is true, that is true.
You think I like being the old woman in these stories?
The men are heroes, the ladies are whores, and the old hags
like me get to watch everyone they love die.
We have very different ways of handling our fate.
Very different means.
Green leaf could be useful.
I don't use it as an excuse to wreck people's lives.
She could be useful.
She's a witch.
Can't she just work for us?
That way she'd be official.
want to reward her for criminal behavior we can't trust this
woman on the 13th it doesn't matter because i'd never do it
i'm not a house cat and i don't play well with others trust
me no one would confuse you for a cuddly animal you're us
sorry thank you order burn the tree no look look i'll tell
you i'll tell you grain was here he was here and he left
yeah he went to the pudding and pie to try to use my ring on
the girls over there to get information.
What does the ring do?
Yeah, what does the ring do?
He thinks it's the ring of dispel.
You know, that it will pierce the protection around the
girl's speech.
He says pulling the truth out of them will prove his
innocence.
It won't, though.
The damn thing lost its power decades ago.
I'm sorry, but we still can't let you keep the tree.
It wouldn't be right after what's happened.
Big B.
Please, Sheriff.
Don't.
I'm hiring you.
Yeah, I think we should hire her.
Snow rejected me already, I think.
We have a glamour shortage as it is.
It makes the most sense, Snow.
I think so, too.
You get to keep your fucking tree.
Just don't expect me to bow down to your little woman here.
Oh!
No, I think it's good to keep her.
Don't think for a second that this is over.
So what?
Are moving trucks going to show up here or something?
Something like that.
We'll call you.
Oh.
I don't know.
I don't think exactly we can trust her.
But I think she also just kind of does things in her best in
her own interest kind of deal, you know?
Completed chapter 5 of episode 3.
But I still think she's useful.
I mean, having a witch to work with you seems pretty
important.
and that's green's car what wait he's just driving around
what if i were this guy i literally would have skipped town
but he's just chilling out around here i don't think so at
least shit hold on oh do you miss a spot mr clean come to
smash up the rest of my place oh i see come to audition you
i'm punching him Ugh!
Fucking fuck, man!
Tell me what you know!
Now!
Oopsie!
You can't just go in there!
I think I can.
We have a problem.
I think I can just go in there.
Just tell me who did it!
I know you know!
Mr. Cray, please!
She can't help!
I know you know what the plan is!
I won't be held accountable for this!
I'm grabbing him!
I can't!
I'm sorry!
I'm grabbing him!
Oh my god.
Big B.
Wait, don't.
Why not?
I didn't do anything.
I promise you, I didn't do anything.
These girls, the girls, they'll back me up.
I just have to get the stupid ring working.
That's all.
I can't talk because of that spell.
But once this ring...
Oh, the spell is what makes them keep their lips sealed.
I had a feeling it was something like that.
That's all.
Please.
I'm innocent.
Completely, completely innocent.
The ring won't work.
Idiot.
Ringleaf soldier.
What?
No.
This will work.
I assure you it must.
I wouldn't- I wouldn't- I am Captain Planet!
Come on.
Please.
Tell me who killed her.
Oh.
My lips are sealed.
I can't say anything actually.
I can't say anything.
Actually.
Oh.
how many years what how many years has this been going on I
mean he's still a sick freak but but he's like such a
weasely man I didn't think he would kill her yeah nothing to
do with that just I just oh god oh my god we found the
photos of you and Lily I know I know that's that was it's
pretty bad it's pretty bad man I just love you, Snow.
I love you, and I'm sorry I'm not Prince Charming, okay?
I'm sorry I didn't cheat on you and run away to Europe.
You don't love me, Crane.
I know what this is.
I've seen it before.
It is not love.
He's just cowering down on the floor.
Ew, don't stupid.
Don't get to his level.
Don't get in it.
Can't even look at you.
yeah I don't think he did it what look at him do you really
think this man murdered these women he's not he wouldn't be
brave enough I agree I agree stamp on the world like that
he's a disgusting coward like there's no reason for him to
have murdered fate away but face did take shut up don't talk
to me what do you mean what do you mean you don't think she
did take the photo if you'd seen the room I don't need to
see the room there's a lot he has to answer for there's a
lot we all have to answer for but this is different snow and
he hired tweedledy and tweedled you said you found evidence
of him defrauding fabletown of using our money for his own
ambitions yeah that's one thing but don't you have doubts
he's a murderer uh yeah I've known him for so long I can't
believe I'm hearing this did you see how he was acting when
you showed up yes I know that's so true too I mean he
definitely his tracks this fuck up knows more than he's
saying yeah 100 i don't i don't yes i do yes okay he
probably does but there's a difference between being
involved and being the guy who did it okay but if crane
didn't kill faith in lily i'm sorry but who the hell did
that's what we're trying to figure out oh this is bigger
than crane you know when i saw you come back here i thought
this was over this whole thing is bigger than crane it
really is who wouldn't have the stones to send Somebody else
is involved.
Oh, shit.
I didn't intend for any of this to get so...
You've been stealing money from Fable Town for years,
haven't you?
Yeah.
This guy is so...
This guy sucks so much.
Ikebaud Crane, you are under arrest for the misappropriation
of Fable Town funds.
You have the right to counsel.
The right to depose witnesses.
But as of right now, you're coming with us.
Yeah, get up.
Get up, you little.
Sometimes it's fuzzy.
Oh, and he's gonna talk back right now.
To run that office?
You think I didn't make sacrifices?
I made sacrifices.
Someone shut this guy up.
And you won't be in that chair one minute before you have to
give up something you care about just so the wheels don't
fall off the goddamn wagon.
This place was not running that- Wait, I'm breaking his
nose.
Okay.
Oh, God.
If I were you, I'd keep that trap of your shot.
This place is running like crap anyway.
You didn't do anything anyway.
So, I don't want to hear it, mister.
Yeah.
Break his nose.
I wonder if we have the guy from...
Sleepy Hollow, where is Mr. Sleepy Hollow?
I want to see that guy.
Oh, okay!
Yeah!
Stupid girls and the preposterous schemes...
What are you saying?
Stupid girls!
Oh, the females are scheming!
Oh!
Who, Dad?
Who are you?
Oh, oh, oh, this is a one-way street.
What are we doing?
This is a dead end.
I think you turned the wrong way.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
This is what's taking my Uber so long.
A second car.
Two of the three of them.
Oh.
Uh-oh, there's the tweedle these, though.
And...
Hi.
What you got there?
Oh, it's so pink.
Oh, my eyes.
Who are you?
Look, it's recently come under our attention that you're...
How should I put this?
Attempting to claim what is the personal property of the
Crooked Man.
The Crooked Man.
He's about yay high, 120-odd pounds.
Pissed his sheets until he was 14.
Sound familiar?
I don't know this fable at all.
I haven't told them anything.
Not now, not now.
Shh.
The grown-ups are talking.
What do you want?
Yeah, what do you want?
That sack of flour.
Crane, dear.
It's Crane.
Oh, no, he's ours.
It wasn't my fault.
Shut up.
Oh my God, thank goodness.
You're interfering with official fable town business.
I don't think they care.
I think if they're working for the...
Twiddle D.
What's the, uh, you know, that thing the Mondays call me?
Uh...
What?
My nickname.
You know what I'm talking about.
Yeah, who are you?
Uh, Bloody Mary.
What?
Wait, that's awesome.
Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary, Bloody
Mary, Bloody Mary.
My name five times in the mirror.
They find it less funny when I actually show up and feed
their lungs to the family dog.
Ah, I don't think that was necessary.
Like golf.
To relax.
Crane.
This is my job.
like my job wrong day to pull this was really the wrong day
to try and pull this yeah I told you he'd never just give
him up she's like shut up you stupid lackey fuck it holy
cow I'm not about to get shot again oh I'm about to get shot
again we're
okay oh I think we're I think I got that dog!
I'm going dog!
Oh,
I got that dog in me!
Q,
Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q.
Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q.
This is, this is our version of the microwave Holloway.
Oh no.
Uh, what did we, I'm just gonna throw the whole thing at
them.
Oh, damn!
What do we got here?
Um, I can bum rush him.
Yeah!
And I'm gonna tear off his face.
Or do that.
And I'm gonna do it again.
And one more time.
And actually one more time.
And again.
And...
Hey!
You really wanna try doing that?
Here I come.
Just throw him on the roof or something.
Like, like...
Oh.
Yeah?
She looks excited.
I can kill him!
I probably shouldn't have done that, but I wanted to send a
message.
You killed Tweedledum.
I imagine most people don't do that.
I am a monster.
Oh it's... she's so impressed.
Is that a silver bullet?
No, it's not.
Why didn't we take care of her first?
I don't understand.
She's obviously the most dangerous one out of the groove.
Why does she have the woodsman's?
You know, you didn't think silver bullets would work on
anything but a pure werewolf.
But as it turns out...
Ah!
Keep, keep, keep, keep, keep!
Please, please!
I'm stronger, I'm stronger, I'm stronger!
I mean, hey, look, I know it sounds ridiculous, but really
that helps.
Can you argue with these results?
I mean, it's complete, but I'm still going.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Wait!
Stop!
Yeah?
Don't give him up.
Don't give that to him.
Don't give him.
Don't do it.
Just take him, okay?
No, Snow White, why?
Just stop, please.
Hmm.
Don't do this!
Snow, don't do this.
Is that the crooked man?
Wait, I want to see him.
Show me your face, you coward.
Oh my god, he's such like a mafia boss.
The crooked man says it's okay with him.
He was in there the whole time.
Hello, Ichabod.
Got a stomach ache.
Oh, my God.
Oh, this is all your fault, mister.
Oh, and just between us girls, Crane ain't no killer.
I mean, look at his face.
Couldn't stick a pig if his life depended.
It's true, Della.
So is it Bloody Mary?
Maybe she's the killer.
Ow!
Oh my god!
A beautiful relationship we have with you guys.
Really?
I mean it.
I'm jazzed about it.
She is so insane.
I'm sure we'll be in touch.
See you around.
So definitely, like, the cooking man is running this place.
And everything.
Oh.
There's not a drive in the car.
Oh, Snow White's face looks so gosh.
This is so bad.
I can't wait to see what kind of consequence killing
Tweedledum does.
He's lucky to be alive.
And he won't be next time if he keeps going like this.
Oh my gosh.
This is getting worse by the minute.
We don't have time to sit around and wait for their next
move.
I'll get there.
things under control.
Woody, I'm not gonna tell you again.
Back off, dog.
This doesn't concern you.
I think this whole thing, I think now whatever is involved
concerns me.
Um, about last night?
Yeah?
When people hear what you did to dumb, they're going to
think you've gone back to your old ways.
So bad.
Don't hold out on me, Jack.
You've always got some angle.
Not this time.
I know when a mark's not worth the trouble.
Do you?
How are people going to to think that we're back to our old
ways.
I don't want it.
You don't want it.
Win.
Literally the crooked man exists.
Do you?
How would they think that?
Unless someone's spinning it that way, you know?
Did you interrupt Snow's eulogy?
You and 80% of players decided not to.
Everybody has tact, right?
let's see what place did you investigate first you and 19
percent of players investigated the tweedle's office first
really really such a small amount of people interesting i'm
kind of curious what was in his place though you know uh you
and 96 of players offered a job to fly catcher i did not
offer him anything i said you could go talk to snow and she
might be able to help you out 49% of players did not burn.
Okay, see, most people thought that keeping her use, keeping
her around would be useful.
You and 44% of players killed Tweedledob.
Wow, that's higher than I imagined.
That's higher.
Nice.
Wow.
What?
A crazy episode.
I still, I think episode two so far has been my favorite.
Just because I think like the whole reveal of like the
glamour and everything was really cool but we do have now
that our big big baddie Mr. The Crooked Man Mr. Crooked Man
isn't that a game?
The Crooked Man?
Like it's like a horror that's the first thing I think of
it's a horror like a RPG maker game it's one of those like
classic RPG horror maker games so Wait, RPG Maker Hork.
But yeah!
Sorry, Tweedledum.
I just wanted to cause a little chaos.
And I wonder how Tweedledee will react about it.
Will he...
Because I think if we kept him alive, for sure, they would
have just stuck with their ways.
But if we killed him...
I mean, he's obviously going to hate us.
Ah, he's gonna hate us more.
I was gonna say, maybe he's just like, no, this wouldn't
have happened if I wasn't following the orders of the
crooked man.
But I know, I don't think he'll think that way.
I think he'll hate us more.
Ooh, interesting.
I truly think Bloody Mary is the one who killed these girls.
Probably with the axe?
Maybe?
Just one whoop.
K'plowey.
But screw this guy.
Crane, that guy sucks.
I hope he gets tortured in the crooked man's office.
We also took the money that he owed him.
We took the money he owed him, so I'm sure he's even more
angry about that.
But awesome!
That's episode 3.
I will see you guys for episode 4 next time!
Next time, next time!
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
I will see you when I see you next!
Outsumita!
I hope you guys are doing well.
And since this is getting uploaded while I'm away, I miss
you guys!
Yeah, I hope you guys are doing well.
I'll see you later.
Otami-do!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye!